This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at it”。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你可以和一个懂行的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. The relationship that we have with our mother,
以及担忧。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎接新生。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是2%（TWO.%）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，我们将在这里剖析二十岁的心理。我们与母亲的关系，
both as children and as we become adults, is one that we don't necessarily speak about enough. but it undoubtedly shapes the people that we become, not just in our 20s, not just in our 30s, but in our 40s, when or if we decide to have children, how we date, how we relate to others, how we relate to ourselves and our bodies. I think it is a tailor's oldest time that each of us takes something from our childhood and from our parents, some of which is good and some of which is less than good, isn't helpful, some of which we come. only really begin to come to terms with the older we get, whether that is, you know, our quirks, our insecurities, our coping mechanisms, the ways that we self-sabotage, I think the more mature we get, the more separation we get from our parents, the more we begin to realize that so much about who we are stems back to how they chose to raise us. And when it comes to our parents, the relationship and the dynamic that we have with our mother and with our father differs
无论是在童年时期还是当我们成年之后，都是一个我们往往讨论不够的话题。但它无疑塑造了我们成为什么样的人，不仅是在20岁，不仅是在30岁，甚至在40岁时，当我们决定或者如果不决定要孩子的时候，我们如何约会，我们如何与他人建立联系，我们如何与自己和自己的身体建立联系。我认为，我们每个人都会从童年和父母那里带走一些东西，这是自古以来的常识，其中有些是好的，有些则没那么好，甚至无益，有些东西我们要到年纪渐长时才真正开始接受，无论是我们的怪癖、我们的不安全感、我们的应对机制，还是我们自我破坏的方式。我认为我们越成熟，与父母的距离越远，我们就越开始意识到，关于我们是谁的很多事情，都可以追溯到他们选择如何抚养我们。而说到我们的父母，我们与母亲以及与父亲的关系和动态截然不同。
greatly. And so it's going to create its own unique pattern of so-called wounds. And that is exactly what we are going to be talking about today. We're going to examine the psychology of mother wounds and how our unique relationship with this caregiver, this person who raised us, who shaped us, can actually cause some damage and some hidden elements of who we are that we might not necessarily like. Even if you think this topic doesn't apply to you or you think that the idea of a wound is a bit dramatic, I'm just going to tell you there is something each of us is going to be able to relate to in this discussion, even if you don't think it now, because the bond that we have with our mothers is so primal and so strong and so important that it leaves a mark on each of us, a mark that we
因此，它会产生自己独特的所谓“创伤”模式。这正是我们今天要讨论的内容。我们将探讨母亲创伤的心理学，以及我们与这位抚养我们、塑造我们的照顾者的独特关系，实际上是如何造成一些伤害的，以及我们身上可能并不喜欢的那些隐藏部分。即使你认为这个话题与你无关，或者你觉得“创伤”这个概念有点戏剧化，我要告诉你的是，我们每个人都能在这场讨论中找到共鸣，即使你现在不这么认为。因为我们与母亲的羁绊是如此原始、强烈且重要，以至于它在我们每个人身上都留下了印记——一个我们
eventually come to terms with. It's not that our mothers are to blame for everything that is wrong with our lives. It's not that every problem stems back to them. Just that when we explore this dynamic a little bit more, we begin to, I think, make visible some things about ourselves that are normally hidden. And that is exactly what we're going to do today. We are going to discuss the origins of mother wounds, how they differ from our father wounds in two critical ways. Five of the most common kind of types of wounds or inherited patterns of behavior that you might recognize yourself in and how to kind of break the generational cycle, how to heal, what to do, what to read, what to investigate, what to explore about yourself. There is so much to talk about when it comes
最终会去面对的印记。这并不是说我们的母亲应该为我们生活中的所有问题承担责任。并不是说每个问题都可以追溯到她们身上。只是当我们更多地探讨这种动态时，我想，我们会开始让一些关于我们自己的、通常被隐藏的事情变得清晰可见。而这正是我们今天要做的。我们将讨论母亲创伤的根源，它们在两个关键方面与父亲创伤有何不同；你可能会在其中看到自己影子的五种最常见的创伤或继承的行为模式；以及如何打破代际循环，如何疗愈，该做什么，该读什么，该调查什么，该探索关于自己的什么。说到
to our mother dynamic and our quote unquote mummy issues. So without further ado, let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs, when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers,
我们与母亲的动态以及所谓的“恋母情结”，有太多话题要聊了。废话少说，我们马上开始。2%。在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例就是2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的方法。我将与作家、研究人员
and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以抛开那些充斥着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎接新生。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking What the hell does George Bush gotta do a little count Well you can find out On the Look Back at it podcast
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是2%。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（戳）小肯（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick it here unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it Including a recent episode
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
With Mark Lamont Hill Waxing all about crack In the 80s To be clear 84 is big to me Not just because of crack I'm down to talk about crack On day
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一集。
But yeah yeah Literally But just so you all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊快克。
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
但话说回来，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还谈到了艾滋病。谢谢你帮我把话说完。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序上收听《Look Back at it》，
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是您的主持人、您最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search, learn the hard way, and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself, at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a
你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？还是说你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客中进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话，
years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
《Learn the Hardway》。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hardway”，立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. I guess the lesbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这段特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your The mother-child relationship is a profoundly important one. It is almost spiritual, in a sense. It's our first example of love. It is the first time we experience safety and protection and self-esteem. There is this beautiful quote that says, our mothers are our first homes. We are always trying to return to them. But I think that doesn't mean that there is unprocessed trauma in that. In that relationship that isn't passed down without our knowledge, that there isn't things that
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，还有迈克尔·马兰奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
every parent, I think, does wrong that influence our relationship with ourselves, as well as those around us on a very physical, social, mental, and emotional level. I think we all know that how we were raised impacts our adult personality and our self-expression from very core concepts like attachment style to our interpersonal skills, our personality, our way of relating to others, our values. There is a whole library and litany of ways in which our childhood environment ends up replicating itself in our adult behaviours. But it kind of begins so much earlier than our memories can recall. It begins all the way back in the womb. There have been more and more studies revealing to us that our adult behavior is being formed before we even open our eyes,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts收听《Love Trapped》播客，或者在您获取...母子关系极其重要。从某种意义上说，它几乎是神圣的。这是我们对爱的最初体验。这是我们第一次体验到安全、保护和自尊。有一句美妙的名言说，我们的母亲是我们最初的家。我们总是试图回到她们身边。但我想这并不意味着其中不存在未处理的创伤。在那段关系中，有些东西在不知不觉中被传递了下来，每个父母，
before we are even sentient beings. And it's being formed by our mother's experiences and our mother's stress and our mother's memories. So this is a phenomena known as fetal programming, whereby our mother's emotional state can actually impact how our brains develop when we are still in the womb. And I think a lot of these studies go to show how deeply linked we are to this person, to our mother, the person who birthed us, who grew us for nine months on quite a biological level, what she experiences is passed through to us. And this is also supported by evidence that traumatic
我想，都会做错一些事情，这些事情会以非常实质性的、社会的、精神的和情感的层面影响我们与自己以及周围人的关系。我想我们都知道，我们的养育方式会从非常核心的概念（如依恋风格）到我们的人际交往能力、个性、与他人相处的方式、我们的价值观，影响我们的成年个性和自我表达。有一整套丰富多样的方式，让我们的童年环境最终在我们的成年行为中自我复制。但这一切开始的时间比我们的记忆所能回溯的要早得多。它一直追溯到子宫里。越来越多的研究向我们表明，我们的成年行为甚至在我们睁开眼睛之前就已经在形成了，
experiences, even generations before, can be passed down epigenetically, meaning that our mother, our grandmother, her mother, they leave an almost chemical mark on our genes and how they are expressed that lasts generations. So the way that they discovered this was through a few different avenues or through different means, a few different situations. So firstly, way back in the 1800s after the US Civil War, researchers began to notice worse life outcomes for the offspring of prisoners of war during that situation and the children of these offspring in ways that didn't really
甚至在我们成为有意识的生命之前。它是由我们的母亲的经历、母亲的压力和母亲的记忆塑造的。因此，这是一种被称为胎儿编程的现象，母亲的情绪状态实际上会影响我们仍在子宫里时大脑的发育。我认为许多这些研究都表明，我们与这个人——我们的母亲、生下我们、让我们在她体内生长了九个月的人——有着多么深厚的联系，在相当生物学的层面上，她所经历的会传递给我们。这也是有证据支持的，即创伤
line up with what we thought about reproduction, which is that when children are born, they are a blank slate. It wasn't just about the kind of economic conditions that these, you know, war veterans found themselves in. It wasn't just around what these children were being taught. It seemed that on a very genetic, basic, biological level, these children were inheriting certain stress responses, certain fears, certain behavioral problems that stemmed back to their parents' experiences. Again, after World War II and the Holocaust, researchers in 2015 found that children and grandchildren of those who had survived this
经历，甚至几代人之前的经历，都可以通过表观遗传学传递下来，这意味着我们的母亲、我们的祖母、她的母亲，她们在我们的基因以及基因如何表达上留下了几乎是化学性质的印记，这种印记可以持续好几代人。所以他们发现这一点是通过几个不同的途径或手段，几种不同的情况。首先，早在1800年代美国内战之后，研究人员开始注意到，在那种情况下战俘的后代以及这些后代的子女，生活结果更差，这种方式并不能真正地
horrific experience had epigenetic changes that increased how they responded to fear and how they coped with stress and their predisposition to certain mental illnesses. And this was a human study, but it replicated an animal study that was conducted probably like three years before that that was kind of going on at the same time. that found that essentially when we had rats in this environment where they were conditioned to associate the smell of something in particular like cherry blossom with pain, even generations later, their offspring was still reacting negatively and disproportionately to that smell. Even though the children of these mice had never experienced the pain themselves,
符合我们对生殖的看法，即孩子出生时是一张白纸。这不仅仅是关于这些退伍军人所处的经济条件。这不仅仅是关于这些孩子被教导了什么。似乎在一个非常基因的、基础的、生物学的层面上，这些孩子们继承了某些应激反应、某些恐惧、某些可以追溯到他们父母经历的行为问题。同样，在二战和大屠杀之后，2015年的研究人员发现，那些在这场可怕经历中幸存下来的人的子女和孙子女，具有表观遗传变化，这增加了他们对恐惧的反应方式、应对压力的方式以及对某些精神疾病的易感性。这是一项人类研究，但它复制了一项大约在三年前进行的、与此大致同时进行的动物研究。
even when they were separated from their like mice parents, there was something going on in our DNA that was adapting to the environment of our mother and the environment of our father. It kind of reminds me of this quote that trauma is an echo that only our descendants can hear. That is pretty profound and it seems that science confirms it. Our mother's experiences, even before we arrive, are going to impact us greatly through our development and therefore our reality after we're born. And those experiences won't just impact us genetically or on a DNA developmental level, but also in terms of how she chooses to parent us, what she impresses on us,
该研究发现，本质上，当我们在这种环境中养老鼠时，它们被条件反射地将某种特定气味（如樱花）与疼痛联系起来，甚至在几代人之后，它们的后代仍然对这种气味做出消极的和不成比例的反应。尽管这些老鼠的后代从未亲身经历过这种疼痛，
her perception of our relationship, her insecurities, her fears about the world and where we, as her child, sit within that space. That is perhaps the biggest distinction between the importance of mother wounds and father wounds. There is this additional layer of connection between us. and our mother, this kind of flesh and blood bond. And it's not to say that that means we're always going to be closer with our moms and that they're always going to be our favorite parent. Our fathers have like no role, no responsibility at all. It all comes back to mom. Absolutely not. It's just that it's different. If you want to hear more about the impact of father wounds,
甚至当它们与它们的鼠父母分开时，我们的DNA中仍然有一些东西在适应我们母亲和父亲的环境。这让我想起了一句名言：创伤是一声只有我们的后代才能听到的回响。这相当深奥，而且科学似乎证实了这一点。我们母亲的经历，甚至在我们到来之前，就会通过我们的发育以及我们出生后的现实，对我们产生巨大的影响。这些经历不仅会在基因或DNA发育层面上对我们产生影响，还会通过她选择如何抚育我们、她给我们留下什么印象、
we did do like a whole episode on that, a few months back episode. I think it's 181. The psychology of father wounds. equally important, but something I say in that episode that I think is important in this context as well, and in distinguishing where your, you know, childhood wounds are coming from is that each of us kind of has this voice in our head, right? It's the same voice that criticizes us, the same voice that judges us, that scolds us, and it's going to sound more like your mother or more like your father. And I think that is a really great way to identify where your parental wounds are stemming from and not who is responsible, but who they're really in connection with. The other distinction is that father wounds are typically more grounded in problems with authority
她对我们关系的感知、她的不安全感、她对世界的恐惧以及我们作为她的孩子在这个空间中的位置，对我们产生影响。这也许是母源创伤和父源创伤的重要性之间最大的区别。在我们与母亲之间，存在着这种额外的连接层，
and independence and approval, whereas mother wounds are just naturally more emotive and concern self-esteem, self-worth, boundary issues, codependency, a fear of rejection, even excessive of people pleasing. We learn a lot from our mothers, perhaps the majority from our mothers, about how to relate to others on an emotional level. As stereotyped as that may be, it is just the case that normally our mothers are conditioned to take on that role as emotional provider and teacher because that's what they learn from their mothers. It's a whole generational, historical, traditional thing. And for women in particular, our mothers also teach us how to operate in a patriarchal society. That is the second big factor that distinguishes mother wounds and father wounds.
这种血肉相连的羁绊。这并不是说这意味着我们总是会和妈妈更亲近，她们也总是会成为我们最喜欢的父母。我们的父亲没有任何角色，没有任何责任。一切都归结于妈妈。绝对不是。只是它们有所不同。如果你想更多地了解父亲创伤的影响，
Mother wounds involve understanding that mothers and daughters, especially, are situated in and influenced by a patriarchal society that is oppressive to women. The mother wound is normally a cultural trauma that is carried by our mother. A long-wound. with the dysfunctional coping mechanisms that she has used to process the pain and adapt to the environment in which she was raised in that she wants us to be capable of surviving as well. And so we inherit her way of managing some of the burdens that society unduly places on women. So I think that we can see this patriarchal influence in some of the most common and prevalent types of mother wounds, such as poor body confidence and self-esteem, jealousy, competition
我们几个月前确实做过一整集关于那个主题的节目。我想是第181集。父亲创伤的心理学。同样重要，但我在那一集里说过的一句话，我认为在这个语境中也很重要，在区分你的童年创伤来自何方时，那就是我们每个人心中都有这样一个声音，对吧？它就是那个批评我们的声音，那个评判我们的声音，那个责备我们的声音，它听起来会更像你的母亲或者更像你的父亲。我认为这是一个很好的方法，可以用来识别你的父母创伤源自何方，不是谁该负责，而是它们真正与谁相连。另一个区别是，父亲创伤通常更多地植根于权威、
with other women, perfectionism, trust issues, fearing disapproval. I think that this facet around patriarchal influence, though, is most noticeable when it comes to how you and I see our bodies and how we see other women. So let's explore that for a second. So I had a friend who once said to me, I hate my body because my mother hated hers. And it flawed me because I think that this encapsulates what we're speaking about perfectly. Our mothers significantly impact the relationship that we have with appearance and with beauty
独立和认可的问题上，而母亲创伤则天生更加情绪化，涉及自尊、自我价值、边界问题、共依存、对被拒绝的恐惧，甚至是过度讨好他人。我们从母亲那里学到了很多东西，也许大部分都来自母亲，关于如何在情感层面上与他人建立联系。尽管这可能是一种刻板印象，但事实确实如此，通常我们的母亲被条件反射地承担起情感提供者和老师的角色，因为她们就是从自己的母亲那里学到这一点的。这是一个代际的、历史的、传统的整体。特别是对于女性而言，我们的母亲还教导我们如何在父权制社会中运作。这是区分母亲创伤和父亲创伤的第二个重要因素。
through verbal messages, through role modelling, through comments on not just our own bodies, but the bodies of other people that we see out in public, in magazines, on the street. They influence us through their own experiences with diet culture and how this almost seeps into our impression and perspective on our own bodies. The words that they speak about themselves in particular truly do get absorbed into our own internal dialogue. If we spend our childhood continuously hearing our mothers talking about how much they hate and despise their thighs and their shoulders and their wrinkles, and their eye color and their hair color. As we grow up, we inherit those very features that they hated. And how is it that we are meant to love that part of us
母亲创伤涉及到理解母亲和女儿（尤其是女儿）身处并受制于一个对女性具有压迫性的父权制社会中。母亲创伤通常是我们的母亲所承载的一种文化创伤。随之而来的还有她用来处理痛苦、适应她长大的环境的不健康的应对机制，而她希望我们也具备这种生存能力。因此，我们继承了她管理社会不公正地加诸于女性身上的一些负担的方式。所以我想我们可以在一些最常见和最普遍的母亲创伤类型中看到这种父权制的影响，比如不良的身体自信和自尊、嫉妒、与其他女性的竞争、完美主义、信任问题、害怕不被认可。然而，我认为围绕父权制影响的这个方面，在涉及你我如何看待自己的身体以及我们如何看待其他女性时最为明显。让我们花一点时间来探讨一下。
that our mother didn't even like about herself? If, as well, they spend our childhood, you know, switching between different yo-yo diets, going keto and then vegan and then doing juice farses, or, you know, throwing all the processed sugar out in the house, which is something that my mom did all the time. ultimately they are going to bring us along with them because they control our environment as well. And so we internalize this behavior as normal.
所以我有一个朋友曾对我说：“我讨厌我的身体，因为我母亲讨厌她的身体。”这让我大吃一惊，因为我认为这完美地概括了我们正在谈论的内容。我们的母亲通过语言信息、通过角色建模、通过对我们自己的身体以及我们在公共场合、杂志上、街上看到的其他人的身体的评论，深刻地影响了我们对外表和美得关系。她们通过自己对节食文化的体验影响我们，而这几乎渗透到我们对自身身体的印象和视角中。特别是她们对自己所说的话，真正被吸收到了我们自己的内部对话中。如果我们整个童年都在不断地听到母亲谈论她们有多么讨厌和痛恨自己的大腿、肩膀、皱纹、眼睛颜色和头发颜色。当我们长大后，我们就会继承那些她们所痛恨的特征。我们怎么可能去爱我们身上那部分连我们的母亲自己都不喜欢的地方呢？
And we believe that our bodies, our size deserves to be controlled and in some ways punished. It's where like the concept of an almond mom came from, you know, a mother who unintentionally gives incredibly unhelpful and unhealthy dieting advice that is projecting her own. securities onto her children, right? It has nothing to do with us and everything that she decides to place worth in and to place value in, such as beauty and thinness. As one doctor put it in this article I read, this phenomenon of almond mums, it's been going on for a long time. Therefore, it's generational, but it's also rooted in diet culture. It's rooted in internalized biases, fat phobia, a projection of fear and this pursuit of thin privilege rather than health. All these behaviours implicitly influence our body image, our self-esteem, and the younger that
同样，如果她们在我们的童年时期，在各种不同的疯狂节食之间切换，一会生酮一会纯素，然后又做果汁断食，或者把家里所有的精制糖都扔掉（这是我妈妈经常做的事）。最终她们会把我们一起拉进去，因为她们也控制着我们的环境。因此，我们将这种行为内化为正常的。
we're exposed, the more deeply ingrained it can become. That is a mother wound that is not spoken about enough, the inheritance of not body positivity, but body negativity. And, you know, speaking with my own friends and the people around me, I think that There are very few of us who are not left unscathed by this in a way. Another wound that really seems to derive from that influence of misogyny and patriarchy on parenting is the tendency to almost feel a little bit competitive with other women. Now, I was discussing this with a friend recently in regards to job hunting and then also like
并且我们相信我们的身体、我们的身材应该被控制，并在某些方面受到惩罚。这就是“杏仁妈妈”（almond mom）这个概念的由来，你知道的，就是一个无意中给出极其无益和不健康的节食建议的母亲，她将自己的不安全感投射到孩子身上，对吧？这与我们无关，而完全与她决定赋予价值和意义的东西有关，比如美貌和骨感。正如我在读的一篇文章中一位医生所说，这种“杏仁妈妈”的现象已经持续很长时间了。因此，它是代际相传的，但也植根于节食文化。它植根于内化的偏见、对肥胖的恐惧、对恐惧的投射，以及对“瘦子特权”的追求，而不是为了健康。所有这些行为都隐性地影响着我们的身体形象、我们的自尊，而且我们接触得越早，它就根深蒂固得越深。这是一种讨论度不够的母亲创伤，即不仅没有继承身体积极性，反而继承了身体消极性。而且，你知道的，与我自己的朋友以及我周围的人交谈时，我认为
dating, especially like dating in our 20s. And she said something really, really interesting. She said, I'll kind of like paraphrase here, but she explained how our mothers and our grandmothers were some of the very first generations to have even like a smidge of increased freedom to choose a career, to date freely, to appreciate kind of some of the benefits of that sexual and female liberation movement of the 60s. But in that experience, they also were pitted against each other in a lot of circumstances because the opportunities were so, you know, like unequal, like there were just not many of them. So there was always this sense of competition, especially with other women. I read this explanation that a lot of women in that generation realized that the opportunities for them were still quite slim and they were also still very much based on male approval. And so they saw that as something to fight over, which they then passed
我们当中很少有人能在这方面毫发无伤。另一种似乎源于厌女症和父权制对育儿影响的创伤，是几乎对其他女性产生一种竞争意识的倾向。现在，我最近和一位朋友讨论过这个问题，关于找工作，还有约会，特别是像我们在二十多岁时的约会。她说了非常非常有趣的一句话。她说——我在这里做个大概的阐述——她解释了我们的母亲和祖母是如何成为最早的一代人之一，她们甚至对选择职业、自由约会拥有哪怕一丝一毫的增加的自由，去欣赏60年代性与女性解放运动的一些好处。但在那种经历中，在很多情况下，她们也被挑起彼此对抗，因为机会太（你知道的）不平等了，机会太少了。因此，总是有一种竞争感，尤其是与其他女性的竞争。我读到过这样一种解释：那一代的许多女性意识到，她们的机会仍然相当渺茫，而且很大程度上仍然建立在男性认可的基础上。因此，她们将此视为争夺的对象，然后她们将这种观念传给她们的女儿，对吧？就像将其他女性视为竞争对手一样，这在很大程度上源于这样一个事实：我们中的许多人仍然认同，而且我们的母亲尤其认同，女性仍然是社会中处于支配地位较弱的性别。因此，当需要争取机会时，就会产生一种更具攻击性的需求，一种更残酷、更努力工作、但同时又要更有礼貌的需求，并且将其他女性视为可能危及你利益的人，无论是找工作、搞事业，还是寻找伴侣。
on to their daughters, right? It's like viewing other women as competition is very much derived from the fact that a lot of us still appreciate, and our mothers in particular appreciate that women are still the less dominant sex in society. And so there is this need to be more aggressive when it comes to asking for opportunities, this need to be more cutthroat, to work harder, but to also be more polite, and to see other women as something that could jeopardize that for you, whether that is when it comes to jobs, when it comes to careers, when it comes to finding a partner.
说实话，如果你深入了解这一点，如果你阅读一些关于这方面的文章，你会感到非常受启发，心想：哇，她们可能甚至没有明确地理解自己在做什么，但一直存在着一种将女性视为竞争对手而不是女性朋友的感觉。所以我想这些是其中的两个方面，我们许多人都可以产生共鸣，
Honestly, if you read into this, if you read some of the articles around this, it is so enlightening to be like, wow, like they may not have even, you know, explicitly understood what they were doing, but there was always this sense of like women as competitors rather than women as friends. So those are two ways I think a lot of us can relate to
当涉及到具有文化和父权根源的母亲创伤时，特别是如果你也是一个女人和一个女儿。但我也想继续讨论一些更具普遍性、情感色彩的、心理上的创伤，这些创伤围绕着建立稳定的关系、害怕不被认可，以及我认为我们许多人都发现自己深陷其中的慢性讨好他人。在短暂的休息之后，所有这些以及更多内容将为您呈现。2%。
when it comes to mother wounds of a cultural and a patriarchal origin, especially if you're also a woman. and a daughter. But I also want to move on to discussing some of the more general, emotive, psychological wounds that surround forming stable relationships, fearing disapproval, and also the chronic people pleasing that I think a lot of us find ourselves trapped in. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%.
那是选择走楼梯的人的比例，在有电梯可用的情况下。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的方法。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以抛开那些充斥着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world,
其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎接新生。在i-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是2%。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross
在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（戳）小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。
double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近的一集。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊快克，但只是让你们大家知道。我是说，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还谈到了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是您的主持人、您最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的经验
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们依然在追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？还是说你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
绝对是。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客中进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话，
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
《Learn the Hardway》。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hardway”，立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这段特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，还有迈克尔·马兰奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When people kind of talk about mummy issues, which is essentially just a very colloquial way of describing mother wounds, what they're normally referring to is a difficulty in dating, informing relationships, maintaining healthy, stable adult relationships because that original bond that we had with our mother was unhealthy during childhood. You have to remember that for most of us, our first existence, of what it meant to be cherished and loved and cared for, what it meant to trust and what it meant to
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当人们谈论“恋母情结”（mummy issues）时，这本质上只是描述母亲创伤的一种非常通俗的说法，他们通常指的是在约会、建立关系、维持健康稳定的成年关系方面存在困难，因为我们在童年时期与母亲的最初羁绊是不健康的。你必须记住，对于我们大多数人来说，我们对被珍视、被爱、被照顾的最初体验，对信任的含义以及
feel safe was our mother and that connection that we had with her. And there are so many ways that that can actually go quite wrong, especially when it comes to our attachment to them. It might include circumstances of emotional neglect, of enmeshment and parenthification or controlling behaviors initiated by our mothers. They don't let us go and make our own mistakes. They don't let us be our own people or even narcissistic abuse. And normally when we are in that environment where the relationship that we have with our mother and childhood and adolescents wasn't allowed to form naturally and normally, two things end up happening that fall under the umbrella of mummy issues. The first is that we form a really unhealthy closeness to our mothers, normally because they
感到安全的含义，就是我们的母亲以及我们与她的那种联系。这种情况实际上可能会出很多问题，特别是在我们对她们的依恋方面。它可能包括情感忽视的情况、纠缠（enmeshment）和父子化（parenthification），或者是我们的母亲发起的控制行为。她们不让我们去放手犯错。她们不让我们成为我们自己，甚至不让我们成为独立的个体，或者甚至是自恋虐待。通常，当我们处于那种环境中，即我们在童年和青春期与母亲的关系没有被允许自然正常地形成时，最终会有两类属于“恋母情结”范畴的事情发生。第一种是，我们与母亲形成了极其不健康的亲密关系，通常是因为她们
depend on us for some kind of emotional need, right? Or they do everything for us. They enmesh themselves in our lives. They don't allow us to separate. That often happens in men. And it often, you know, results in them looking for someone to fulfill that same role. They don't understand that that relationship and that dynamic is not appropriate, that there isn't somebody who is going to be their mother, who is going to do everything for them, who is going to serve them. Or the second thing that happens is that we push back
某种情感需求而依赖我们，对吧？或者她们为我们做一切事情。她们将自己纠缠进我们的生活中。她们不允许我们独立。这种情况经常发生在男性身上。这通常会导致，你知道的，他们寻找某人来扮演那个相同的角色。他们不明白这种关系和动态是不合适的，没有人会成为他们的母亲，会为他们做一切事情，会伺候他们。或者发生的第二种情况是，我们抵制
against any kind of relationship that replicates or mimics the closeness and dependency that we have with our mother, because we understand what it means to be that emotionally tied to somebody and then perhaps hurt. So we get and we become quite cynical when it comes to love. We find it hard to trust. This might result from perhaps your parents getting a divorce and your mom maybe didn't handle it well. She kind of separated for a little while.
任何复制或模仿我们与母亲的亲密感和依赖性的关系，因为我们懂得了与某人在情感上如此紧密相连然后可能受到伤害意味着什么。因此，我们在面对爱情时变得相当愤世嫉俗。我们发现很难信任他人。这可能是由于你的父母离婚了，而你妈妈可能没有处理好。她独自生活了一小段时间。
She, you know, took a step back. Maybe you didn't see her. You felt abandoned or even narcissistic abuse whereby your mother really saw herself as the center of her own universe. She had children to fulfill her own needs and her own wants, which meant that you were kind of always a bit of a puppet. And you both, as children, we have this natural inclination to want to be close to our mother, regardless of how she's treating us, but then also resenting her for those negative emotions that we would be feeling in response to mistreatment, neglect, maltreatment. When somebody comes along that makes us feel a similar way, a sense of, you know, a similar
她，你知道的，退了一步。也许你没有看到她。你感到被遗弃，甚至遭受自恋式虐待，你的母亲真正把自己看作是她自己宇宙的中心。她生孩子是为了满足她自己的需求和愿望，这意味着你某种程度上一直有点像个木偶。而且你们俩，作为孩子，我们都有这种天生的倾向，想要亲近母亲，不管她是怎么对待我们的，但同时也会因为我们在面对虐待、忽视、虐待时所感受到的那些负面情绪而怨恨她。当某个人出现，让我们感觉到类似的感觉，一种，你知道的，类似的
sense of safety, even if it's misplaced, we automatically associate that with, you know, the other foot coming down, the other shoe dropping, which is one of control, which is one of perhaps being let down. So I want to kind of illustrate two examples of this because I feel like that's quite like a broad strokes approach. For example, if your mother parentified you, that's a big instance in which we see mummy issues or mother wounds. In parenthification, what essentially happens is that the role of the parent and the child have been reversed. And so, you, served as her confident. You had to regulate her emotions. There was a level of guilt maybe that she used to get you to do what she wanted. You felt like you had to take care of her. When you reach
安全感，即使这种安全感是错置的，我们也会自动把它与靴子落地、另一只鞋子掉下来联系起来，也就是控制，也就是或许被抛弃的感觉。所以我想举两个这样的例子，因为我觉得这是一种相当概括的方法。例如，如果你的母亲让你扮演了父母的角色，这是一个很好的例子，让我们看到“妈妈问题”或“母亲创伤”。在父母化中，基本上发生的事情是父母和孩子的角色颠倒了。所以，你成了她的知己。你不得不调节她的情绪。她可能用某种程度的罪恶感来让你做她想做的事。你觉得自己必须照顾她。当你到了
your early 20s or adolescence and you naturally start seeking out emotional independence, firstly, your mother might really push back against that and guilt you into believing that you're abandoning her, that you don't love her anymore, you don't see her enough. And you might also, find yourself becoming quite emotionally unavailable. You are scared that you're going to repeat that same bond with somebody else and find yourself increasingly engulfed or enmeshed in their life. Another example that I heard from a listener the other day that she kindly agreed to let me share was her observing how her mother had gotten really caught up in a nasty marriage, in an abusive relationship. She spent a lot of her childhood really constantly wishing that she would leave,
20岁出头或青春期，你自然开始寻求情感独立时，首先，你的母亲可能会强烈抵制这一点，并让你感到内疚，让你相信你在抛弃她，你不再爱她了，你看她不够多。而且你可能也会发现自己变得相当情感冷漠。你害怕你会与别人重复那种联系，并发现自己越来越多地被吞没或卷入他们的生活中。我前几天从一个听众那里听到的另一个例子，她好意同意让我分享，那就是她观察到她的母亲是如何陷入一段糟糕的婚姻、一段虐待关系中的。她的童年有很大一部分时间都在不断地希望她离开，
that her mother would leave, and eventually just kind of realized that she couldn't control what she decided to do. That kind of resulted in her spending a lot of her early 20s resenting her mother for the situation and the environment that she was put through, but also really fearing that she would repeat the example that her mother had set, that there was this generational curse that she was going to see this behaviour as normal and tolerate it herself or accept it herself and end up in the same position. So when she started dating, she was on high alert. She couldn't trust anybody around her because she had seen this example of how her mother, somebody so similar to herself in blood and genetics and relationship had gotten caught up
希望她的母亲离开，最后只是意识到她无法控制自己决定做什么。这导致她20岁出头的很大一部分时间都在怨恨她的母亲所处的境地和环境，但也非常害怕自己会重复母亲树立的榜样，害怕存在这种代际诅咒，认为这种行为是正常的，自己也会容忍或接受，最终落得同样的下场。所以当她开始约会时，她处于高度戒备状态。她无法信任周围的任何人，因为她看到了这样一个例子：她的母亲，一个在血缘、基因和关系上与她如此相似的人，是如何陷入
in this terrible situation that had resulted in her getting hurt. So I think these situations they go to show yet again how much we take on from our mothers. And the kind of invisible influence, they will inevitably have over our adult choices and experiences, especially when it comes to love. I think whilst the love that we share with our mother may be familiar, once again, I will say it again, it is our first example of what to expect. And so depending on the love your mother showed you or the love that your mother exposed you to in other environments, how maybe you.
这个可怕的境地并导致自己受到伤害的。所以我觉得这些情况再次表明，我们从母亲身上承载了多少东西。以及那种无形的影响，它们不可避免地会对我们的成年选择和经历产生影响，尤其是当涉及到爱情时。我认为，虽然我们与母亲分享的爱可能是熟悉的，但我还是要再次强调，它是我们对期望的第一个例子。因此，根据你的母亲向你展示的爱，或者你的母亲在其他环境中让你接触到的爱，也许还有
even that connection was manipulated in some respects, it can create some wounds. I want to give you two final examples of kind of mother wounds that we see quite often, even if we don't have a label for it, that don't typically fall into like the mummy issues in a dating sense. Like they're a bit more broad and therefore perhaps don't receive as much recognition. The first is around fearing disapproval. And we see that, this a lot in people whose mothers were quite overbearing or who were perfectionists themselves. If our mothers were highly critical of us, maybe it was that they were kind of projecting their own desire for success and admiration and achievement onto us. They were looking to us as a proxy
这种联系在某些方面是如何被操纵的，它会造成一些创伤。我想给你最后举两个我们经常看到的母亲创伤的例子，即使我们没有给它贴上标签，它们通常不属于约会意义上的“妈妈问题”。它们更广泛一些，因此可能没有得到那么多的认可。首先是关于害怕不被认可。我们在那些母亲相当专横或自己就是完美主义者的家庭中经常看到这一点。如果我们的母亲对我们极其挑剔，也许是因为她们将自己对成功、赞赏和成就的渴望投射到了我们身上。她们把我们当作实现她们所有愿望的代理人
for them to fulfill all of their wishes for having a successful career, for being brilliant, for being praised. And so they see us as an example of her choices and as an example of her morals and her greatness for other people to observe rather than seeing us as independent people who are, you know, growing up on our own and who want to do our own thing and who want to become our own person and be happy in our own achievements. We were kind of an extension of her. And that's where her need to really bear down on us and control our behavior came from. That's where her need to be involved in everything came from. I think when we are raised in that environment and we have a mother of that nature who is kind of being compelled to treat us that way, we begin to conflate a lot of our
我们要拥有成功的事业，我们要表现出色，我们要受到赞扬。因此，她们把我们视为她选择的榜样，视为她的道德和伟大的榜样，供其他人观察，而不是把我们看作是独立的人，你知道的，我们在靠自己成长，想要做我们自己的事，想要成为我们自己的人，并在我们自己的成就中获得快乐。我们某种程度上是她的延伸。这就是她需要严格压制我们并控制我们的行为的原因。这就是她需要参与一切的原因。我认为，当我们成长于那种环境中，并且有一个那种性格的母亲，迫使她这样对待我们时，我们开始把我们的许多
achievements and material accolades with our self-worth. And so as we get older, when we don't have that external validation or that external pressure from our parents, from our mother to succeed when we don't have our mother keeping us on track, keeping us disciplined. We end up kind of declining in performance. We end up having to question who we actually are without her around, without her pushing us. And we also, in a way, lack confidence in our own decisions. We question our own choices because our mother always had control over them. We never really got a say and so we never really began to build that independent muscle, that independent skill set. I think this kind of disapproving, impossible to please mother figure also makes us crave validation
成就和物质荣誉与我们的自我价值混为一谈。因此，随着年龄的增长，当我们没有来自父母、来自母亲的外部认可或外部成功压力时，当我们没有母亲让我们保持正轨、保持纪律时。我们的表现最终会有所下降。我们最终不得不质疑，如果没有她在身边，没有她的推动，我们究竟是谁。而且我们在某种程度上也对自己的决定缺乏信心。我们质疑自己的选择，因为我们的母亲总是对它们拥有控制权。我们从未真正拥有发言权，因此我们也从未真正开始建立那种独立的肌肉、那种独立的技能。我认为这种不赞成、永远无法取悦的母亲形象也让我们渴望得到认可
or constantly seek out ways to impress her or another maternal authoritative figure. The way that we could never impress our mother as a child, we start looking for ways to impress, you know, strong females and strong women in our lives as an adult. So finally we have chronic people pleasing. I'm thinking about this now. We probably should have talked about this when we were discussing the links between mother wounds, mother-daughter dynamics and patriarchy. But that time has passed.
或者不断寻找能让她或另一个女性权威形象印象深刻的方法。我们在童年时期永远无法给母亲留下深刻印象的方式，开始变成在成年后寻找给生活中的强大女性和强悍女性留下深刻印象的方法。最后，我们有慢性讨好型人格。我现在想到了这一点。在我们讨论母亲创伤、母女动态和父权制之间的联系时，我们可能本该讨论这个。但那个时间已经过去了。
We're going to talk about it now. Something we know as a fact is that women are more likely to be people-pleases because of our conditioned role as caretakers, managing the emotions of others, suppressing our needs for those around us, keeping the pace, maintaining like the harmony, especially as women, its daughters, who do we learn that from? Normally, our mothers, through observational learning, to seeing how they adapt and respond to what others require of them and how they sacrifice themselves, their emotions, their boundaries, their rest for other people.
我们现在要讨论它。我们作为一个事实所知道的是，女性更有可能成为讨好型人格，因为我们被规训的角色是照顾者、管理他人的情绪、压抑自己的需求来迎合周围的人、保持步伐、维持和谐，尤其是作为女性，作为女儿，我们是从谁那里学到这一点的？通常是我们的母亲，通过观察学习，通过看她们如何适应和回应他人的需求，以及她们如何为了其他人牺牲自己、自己的情绪、自己的界限和休息。
and we see how they behave. We watch them for all those years and we kind of take that as a lesson on how we should act and who we should be as women, as caregivers, as providers. It is known as the people pleasing or the pushover wound. Sometimes that can also manifest in resentment, right? Feeling like our mother never taught us how to stand up for ourselves, never showed us that we could be brave, we could be more courageous, we could be better at setting boundaries.
我们看到她们的行为。我们看着她们度过了好多年，我们把这当作一门课程，学习我们作为女性、作为照顾者、作为提供者应该如何行事，应该成为什么样的人。这被称为讨好型人格或软柿子创伤。有时这也会表现为怨恨，对吧？觉得我们的母亲从未教过我们如何为自己挺身而出，从未向我们展示我们可以勇敢，我们可以更有勇气，我们可以更好地设定界限。
And because she didn't do that, we have ended up as somebody who was always living for others. I think it's okay to feel angry about that, but still love your mother at the same time and still understand why she did what she did to think about what you would have done differently in that circumstance if you were raising yourself all over again, but also knowing that as simple as it sounds, she was doing the best she could. I do genuinely believe that our parents very much operate. at the ceiling of what they believe they are capable of giving us. With each generation though, that ceiling is going to get higher.
正因为她没有这样做，我们最终成了一个总是为别人活着的人。我认为，对这一点感到愤怒是可以的，但同时仍然爱你的母亲，并且仍然理解她为什么会做她所做的事，去想想如果你重新抚养自己，在那种情况下你会做些什么不同的事情，同时也知道，听起来很简单，她已经尽力了。我真的相信我们的父母在很大程度上是在他们认为自己有能力给予我们的上限内运作的。然而，随着每一代人的成长，这个上限会越来越高。
And our emotional intelligence, our resources hopefully expand. We learn from their mistakes. And so if we one day decide to raise our own children, we take everything that we saw them perhaps do wrong, their missteps, and we ensure that we don't do the same thing. I think speaking of our own children, speaking of generations, the wounds that we do carry from our mothers, I think, influence our perspective on wanting to be mothers ourselves and wanting to have children someday and whether we'll be any good at it.
我们的情商、我们的资源有望得到扩展。我们从他们的错误中吸取教训。所以，如果我们有一天决定抚养自己的孩子，我们就会吸取我们看到他们可能做错的所有事情、他们的失误，并确保我们不会做同样的事情。我认为说到我们自己的孩子，说到代际，我们从母亲那里承载的创伤，我认为，会影响我们对自己想要成为母亲、想要在某天有孩子的看法，以及我们是否能胜任。
This is not something that we speak about very much, especially in our early or mid-20s, having children, how we should raise them. It feels like a very far-off reality, a far-off fantasy for a lot of people, myself included. Perhaps it's not something that you're interested in at all, which is also super fair. But the older we get, I think the more aware we do become, whether you want children or not, of how our unresolved or unhealed wounds will be passed down and will impact those around us. Mother and father wounds are, in a sense, inherited, but they are also contagious. And not contagious in like the viral, bacterial sense of the world.
这不是我们经常谈论的事情，尤其是在我们20岁出头或二十多岁中期，关于生孩子，我们应该如何抚养他们。对许多人来说，包括我自己，这感觉像是一个非常遥远的现实，一个非常遥远的幻想。也许这根本不是你感兴趣的事情，这也是完全可以理解的。但随着我们年龄的增长，我认为我们会越来越意识到，无论你想不想要孩子，我们未解决或未治愈的创伤将如何被代代相传，并影响我们周围的人。母亲和父亲的创伤在某种程度上是遗传的，但它们也是会传染的。这里的传染不是指病毒、细菌意义上的传染，
but in the sense that the more exposure you have to unheeled wounds, the more likely that the behavior of that person will inevitably influence your own behavior as well. And your unheeled wounds may be doing that to those around you. And I think this is where the devotion to healing and the necessity of healing really comes from. If it was just you who was suffering, honestly, that would be bad enough. would be hard enough. You deserve more. You deserve to really know yourself outside and within this space and to understand how you are the way that you are. But it's also this sense that eventually, you know, the person that you have become because of how you were raised and your quirks,
而是指你接触未治愈创伤越多，那个人的行为就越不可避免地会影响你自己的行为。而你未治愈的创伤可能正在对你周围的人产生这种影响。我想这就是对疗愈的奉献和疗愈的必要性真正来源的地方。如果只是你一个人在受苦，老实说，那已经够糟糕的了，已经够艰难的了。你值得拥有更多。你值得在这个空间之外和之内真正了解自己，并理解你为什么会成为现在的样子。但这也是一种感觉，最终，你知道的，因为你的成长方式和你的怪癖，你所变成了的那个人，
your insecurities, these small coping mechanisms, these big, perhaps maladaptive coping mechanisms that you have adopted may end up sabotaging what you want from life. They may end up sabotaging your romantic relationships, your friendships, and eventually, again, if you decide to have children, the relationship that you eventually have with your own kids. So I think my biggest advice I have is to process early, but not all at once. It's super amazing that we're considering this in our 20s, right? Honestly, at whatever age, it's important. But I think when we first become aware of these wounds that we might be carrying, it's almost like starting a marathon. It's almost like looking at this massive set of kilometers, this massive task in front of us
你的不安全感，你所采用的这些小的应对机制，这些可能是不良适应的大型应对机制，最终可能会破坏你对生活的期望。它们最终可能会破坏你的恋爱关系、友谊，最后，再次强调，如果你决定要孩子，最终与你自己的孩子的关系。所以我认为我最好的建议是尽早处理，但不要一下子全部处理。我们在20岁时考虑到这一点，真的是太棒了，对吧？老实说，无论在什么年龄，这都很重要。但我认为，当我们第一次意识到我们可能携带的这些创伤时，这几乎就像是开始一场马拉松。这几乎就像是看着这巨大的一公里路程，面前这巨大的任务
and wanting to just jump right in and repair the relationship and fix everything straight away, reverse all the generational trauma straight away. But there are some things that I think we have to do before that. And firstly, that is to really think about what you need. What are the wounds that you feel you need to work through? What is it that you're looking to heal from? What is the impact that you are saying? seeing in your life? What is your emotional experience and where is the origin? What is it coming down
并且想要直接跳进去修复关系，立刻解决所有问题，立刻逆转所有的代际创伤。但在那之前，我认为有些事情是我们必须做的。首先，那就是真正思考你需要什么。你觉得你需要克服哪些创伤？你想要从什么中恢复？你所看到的冲击是什么？你的情感体验是什么，它的根源在哪里？它究竟归结为
to? What part of your mother's behavior? What part of her reactions to the world? What part of her own upbringing? Are they kind of reflecting? I think you need to be clear on where you see the link and the origin and the root coming from before you can come to the table and say, hey, this was my experience and I want to speak about it. Right. If you say, well, I hate my body. but I don't really know how you were involved. It's kind of like, you know, it might not be your mother. It might be something else, and it's kind of hard to work through that experience and to work through this very current reality for yourself.
什么？你母亲行为的哪一部分？她对世界反应的哪一部分？她自己的成长经历的哪一部分？它们在某种程度上反映了什么？我认为你需要弄清楚联系、起源和根源来自哪里，然后才能坐下来谈判，嘿，这就是我的经历，我想谈谈它。对吧。如果你说，嗯，我讨厌我的身体，但我真的不知道你是怎么参与其中的。这有点像，你知道的，可能不是你母亲的问题。可能是别的原因，而要克服那种经历以及对你来说非常现实的现状是很难的。
If you're still kind of ambiguous around where this may have actually come from, it also, I think, is very easy to feel anger before any other emotion because it is such a simple, one-sided emotion. It is so one-track-minded. But anger is not necessarily helpful in these circumstances. It's not necessarily helpful to go in all guns blazing, looking to find someone to blame, looking to find someone to hurt, to scream at, to discuss with.
如果你对这究竟可能来自何处仍然感到有些含糊不清，我认为在任何其他情绪之前也很容易感到愤怒，因为它是一种如此简单、单向的情绪。它是如此的执着。但在这些情况下，愤怒不一定有帮助。气势汹汹地冲进去，寻找替罪羊，寻找可以伤害、可以尖叫、可以争论的人，这不一定有帮助。
Yes, those conversations will eventually need to happen and are important. But I also think that the second component, and the second thing we need to understand before we go about addressing our mother wounds is addressing how we think our mother is, addressing how we think our mother is going to respond. Think about whether she will be able to accept that responsibility, or is it something that you just have to acknowledge that she is the way she is, she did the best she could, and kind of process it on your own.
是的，这些对话最终需要发生并且很重要。但我也认为第二个组成部分，以及我们在着手处理母亲创伤之前需要了解的第二件事是，解决我们如何看待我们的母亲，解决我们认为我们的母亲会如何回应。思考她是否能够承担起那份责任，或者这是否是一件你只能承认她就是那样的人、她已经尽力了，然后自己去消化它的事情。
Sometimes I find, and this is, of course, my own perspective, that our problems and anger can become more entrenched when we look for closure in our parents, because half the time they don't even realize what they did. and half the time they probably don't want to take responsibility out of a human need to protect their ego, one that we all have. No one is going to enjoy being told that they were a bad parent. No one likes taking on blame for the way that we are, especially somebody who feels so personally involved in our development. This isn't to say that a discussion might not one day take place
有时我发现，当然这也是我自己的观点，当我们从父母那里寻找内心平静时，我们的问题和愤怒会变得更加根深蒂固，因为有一半的时间他们甚至没有意识到自己做了什么，有一半的时间他们可能出于保护自己自我的人类需求而不想承担责任，这是我们所有人都有的。没有人会喜欢被告知自己是个糟糕的父母。没有人喜欢为我们的现状承担责备，特别是那些在我们的成长过程中感到如此亲密参与的人。这并不是说有一天不会进行讨论，
and I actually think it's really important, just that you need to be clear on what you actually need out of that conversation, how your emotional experiences and reality relates to your mother wounds, and what you can expect from your parent, what you can expect from your mother. I think the hardest situations are when you go in, you have all this courage to say, hey, like, I feel like you have created an unhealthy pattern in me
而且我实际上认为这真的很重要，只是你需要清楚自己从那场对话中真正需要什么，你的情感经历和现实与你的母亲创伤有何关系，以及你能从你的父母、从你的母亲那里期待什么。我认为最困难的情况是当你走进去，你有所有的勇气去说，嘿，我觉得你在我身上制造了一种不健康的模式
around attention seeking, around validation seeking, around love. And I want to talk about it. I want to understand why you raised me the way you did. And she turns around and goes, well, no, that's not my experience. I'm not that kind of mother. Are you saying that I'm a terrible mother? And suddenly you're shut down. And I think it's something to be prepared for.
围绕着寻求关注、寻求认可、围绕着爱。我想谈谈。我想了解你为什么会这样抚养我。而她转过身来说，不，这不是我的经历。我不是那种母亲。你是说我是个糟糕的母亲吗？然后你突然被拒绝了。我认为这是需要做好心理准备的事情。
You probably know her quite well. What do you think that you're going to get out of that conversation and be realistic with yourself about it and about the closure that you might be available to you before you enter. There are a lot of things that we can do for ourselves when our mother is perhaps not involved, not up for discussing,
你可能很了解她。你认为你能从那场对话中得到什么，对自己保持现实的态度，以及在你进入之前可能获得的内心平静。当我们的母亲可能没有参与、不愿讨论、
not willing to take accountability. I think first is coming to terms with what you are okay with and what you are not in this day and age. The good thing about growing up and maturing, about getting older and finding independence beyond the family unit, is that you kind of get to control your physical and emotional environment from now on. and that means that you have the capacity to say what is no longer okay with you and put in that distance.
不愿意承担责任时，我们可以为自己做很多事情。我认为首先是接受在这个时代你同意什么，不同意什么。长大成熟的好处，随着年龄的增长并在家庭之外找到独立，是你现在基本上可以控制你的物理和情感环境。这意味着你有能力说出什么对你来说不再可以接受，并拉开距离。
For example, comments about your body, about your choices, about what you eat, what you wear, who you date, you can put those things off limits. Maybe that is by saying to your mother, you know, hey, I'm not open to talking about this. I'm not in the mood. Let's talk about something else. Maybe it's that first step of being like, that's actually quite hurtful and, you know, this is what the emotional experience it creates for me. I feel anxious when you say comments about my body. I feel uncomfortable and I don't want that to define our relationship. So maybe that's off limits from now on.
例如，关于你的身体、你的选择、你吃什么、你穿什么、你和谁约会的评论，你可以把这些事情列为禁区。也许可以通过对你母亲说，你知道的，嘿，我不想谈这个。我没心情。我们聊点别的吧。也许这是第一步，比如，这真的很伤人，你知道的，这给我造成了怎样的情感体验。当你对我的身体评头论足时，我感到焦虑。我感到不舒服，我不希望这定义我们的关系。所以也许从现在开始这是禁区。
Maybe we don't discuss it. Not even maybe. That is off limits from now on. We won't be discussing that. Boundaries are spoken about a lot, right? But they are so important in healing these wounds. I think it's equally important to review the other relationships that you have in your life. And whether, you know, that original relationship you have with your mother is
也许我们不讨论它。甚至不只是“也许”。从现在开始那是禁区。我们将不再讨论这个。关于界限，我们谈论得很多，对吧？但它们在疗愈这些创伤时是如此重要。我认为同样重要的是审视你生活中的其他关系。以及，你知道的，你与母亲最初的那种关系是否
influencing how you're, the behaviour that you're accepting from these people, like friends, like partners, like colleagues, are there boundaries that need to be set with them as well that you previously didn't because of this people pleasing wound, because of this kind of self-sabotaging wound, this self-abandonment wound that has directly come from, you know, your mother being overbearing or being absent or training you to be very passive and a bit of a people-pleasing. my final tip is that it's also valuable to address your inner critic that voice we talked about in your head that sounds like your mother or your father if you can recognize that it's your mother's critical voice notice when that speaks up notice where you are feeling it when that voice comes
正在影响你从这些人（如朋友、伴侣、同事）那里接受的行为，是否需要与他们也设定界限，而你以前因为这种讨好型创伤、因为这种自我破坏型创伤、这种自我抛弃型创伤而没有设定，这些直接来自于，你知道的，你的母亲过于专横或缺席，或训练你变得非常被动和有点讨好型人格。我的最后一个建议是，解决你的内心批评者也是很有价值的，我们在你脑海中谈到的那个声音，听起来像你的母亲或父亲。如果你能认出那是你母亲的批判性声音，注意当它发言时，注意当你感觉到它时你在哪里，当那个声音
into play what it is about what is it directed towards do you hear that critical voice when you are perhaps you know not feeling as productive as you usually are are you usually are you hearing that inner voice when, I don't know, you don't fit into the genes that you used to fit into, or when you feel like you've let somebody down, or when you're not pushing yourself hard enough at work, it's really important to identify your inner critic and what it speaks up in response to, because that is normally where the wound is located. Secondly, replace that inner critic with your own voice, one that builds you up, one that is not going to scold you, one that is not going to tear you down for simple, small mistakes
发挥作用时，它是关于什么的，它是针对什么的？当你可能，你知道的，没有平时那么有生产力时，你听到那个批判性声音了吗？当你，我不知道，塞不进以前穿得下的牛仔裤时，或者当你觉得你让某个人失望时，或者当你没有在工作上逼自己足够紧时，你听到那个内心的声音了吗？识别你的内心批评者以及它是在什么回应下开口的真的很重要，因为那通常是创伤所在的位置。其次，用你自己的声音取代那个内心批评者，一个建立你的声音，一个不会责备你的声音，一个不会因为简单的小错误
or parts of your reality that you like and that you accept. It's also important, I think, that when you feel angry, when you get frustrated, or you're feeling misunderstood, or, you know, you're taking on the criticisms, the anxiety, the thoughts of your mother, to separate yourself from that feeling by grounding yourself, doing a repetitive doodle, listening to your favorite album, going for a quick walk, taking a warm shower, detach from the emotions that you have implicitly absorbed from her through your experiences. That doesn't mean that you need to suppress all your negative emotions, more so that you make them manageable so that when, you know,
或你喜欢并接受的现实部分而将你撕裂的声音。我认为同样重要的是，当你感到愤怒、当你感到沮丧、或者你觉得被误解、或者，你知道的，你在承受母亲的批评、焦虑、想法时，通过脚踏实地、涂鸦、听你最喜欢的专辑、去快步走、洗个热水澡来将自己从那种感觉中剥离，让自己脱离通过经历隐式吸收自她的情绪。这并不意味着你需要压抑你所有的负面情绪，更多的是让它们变得可控，以便当，你知道的，
you can kind of take a step back and really identify why you're feeling the way that you are, where that is coming from, and how you can process that without having that kind of cloud of confusion over you, without just being compelled by anger. So finally, there are some books that I would really recommend from people who have spent a lot more time with this subject matter than me. The first one is titled It Didn't Start With You by Mark Wallin. This book is phenomenal and I honestly think that it's a better version of the classic
你可以退后一步，真正确定你为什么会有现在的感受，这从何而来，以及你如何在没有那种困惑的云雾笼罩的情况下，在不被愤怒驱使的情况下处理它。最后，有一些书我真的很推荐，来自那些在这个主题上花费了更多时间的人。第一本是马克·沃林（Mark Wallin）写的《创伤是你开始的吗》（It Didn't Start With You）。这本书太棒了，我老实说它比经典之作
The Body Keeps the Score. It's much more modern. It's much more thorough. He essentially discusses how trauma is essentially hereditary, we know and how the legacy of those memories is passed down to us by way of emotional inheritance, usually from our mothers and their mothers and theirs. And it's super accessible. I would really recommend it. The other one is what my mother and I don't talk about. That is a collection of 15 essays by 15 different writers. And it's very, very revealing and very honest and really examines
《身体会记住一切》（The Body Keeps the Score）更好。它更现代，更彻底。他本质上讨论了创伤本质上是如何遗传的，我们知道的，以及这些记忆的遗产是如何通过情感继承的方式传递给我们的，通常来自我们的母亲、她们的母亲以及她们的母亲。而且它非常容易理解。我真的很推荐它。另一本是《我和母亲不谈论的事》（What My Mother and I Don't Talk About）。那是15位不同作者的15篇文章的合集。它非常非常发人深省，非常诚实，真正审视了
how complicated our relationship with our matriarch and our maternal creator can kind of be. So the reason that this series of essays came to be was that the person who essentially contacted all these women to contribute and who edited the entire anthology, Michelle Philgate, she wrote this essay a while back that went super viral about her coming to terms with her stepfather abusing her. But it actually really turned into like an exploration of how. how that changed her relationship with her mother. And she spoke to 14 other women around what that experience or, you know,
我们与女家长和母亲创造者的关系可以有多复杂。所以这系列文章之所以出现，是因为联系所有这些女性并编辑了整个文集的这个人，米歇尔·菲尔盖特（Michelle Philgate），她前段时间写了一篇关于她接受继父虐待的病毒式传播的文章。但它实际上真正变成了一种探索，关于
a different experience was like for them that kind of changed their perspective towards their mom. So 10 out of 10, I would really recommend it. And as a, you know, a concluding reminder, a concluding affirmation, it's okay to have mixed feelings about your mother as you come to term with the wounds that she may have unintentionally left, right? Like she is kind of and may still be the center of your universe. You may want her attention and love her as much as you have ever loved anybody else and still feel angry and still feel hurt for her not being able to fulfill your maybe emotional needs as a child or for getting it wrong.
那如何改变了她与母亲的关系。她与另外14位女性交谈，关于那种经历，或者，你知道的，不同经历对她们来说是怎样的，这在某种程度上改变了她们对妈妈的看法。所以满分10分，我真的强烈推荐它。作为一个，你知道的，总结性的提醒，一个总结性的肯定，当你接受她可能无意中留下的创伤时，对你的母亲抱有复杂的情感是可以的，对吧？就像她曾经是、可能仍然是你宇宙的中心一样。你可能想要她的注意，像爱任何人一样爱她，但仍然对她无法满足你作为孩子的潜在情感需求或搞砸了感到愤怒和受伤。
You can feel both things at once. That is like the complexity and the nuance of human relationships that we hold multiple feelings for somebody at one time. it doesn't necessarily mean that like this relationship is over that your mother was a terrible person that she meant to hurt you. I think a lot of healing when it comes to healing our mother wounds stems from a place of forgiveness and empathy and realizing why this reality was the one that you had to endure and that you experienced where that came from for your mother and stopping the ball there, making sure that if you choose to have children, it doesn't get passed down or it doesn't get spread
你可以同时感受到这两种情绪。这就是人际关系的复杂性和细微差别，我们在同一时间对某人怀有多种情感。这并不一定意味着这段关系已经结束，你的母亲是个糟糕的人，她是有意伤害你的。我认为在治愈我们的母亲创伤方面，很多治愈源于宽容和同理心，意识到为什么这种现实是你不得不忍受的，你经历过，这对于你的母亲来说从何而来，并在那里停止这个球，确保如果你选择要孩子，它不会被传下去或传播开来，
around, that you don't end up kind of contaminating your relationships with the unhealthy patterns that you've learned from her. So I really do hope that you've enjoyed this episode. I hope you got something out of it. I hope you learned something new. I hope that you, this has helped you heal. If you have any like further questions, further contributions, further experiences that you want to talk about. Please feel free to message me at That Psychology podcast on Instagram. Make sure that you're following us over there so you can vote on future episodes so you know what's kind of coming out and that you're following us on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you are listening right now, leave us a five-star review or subscribe if you would like and make sure
确保你不会最终用从她那里学到的不健康模式来污染你的关系。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我希望你从中有所收获。我希望你学到了新东西。我希望这能帮助你疗愈。如果你有任何进一步的问题、进一步的贡献、想要谈论的进一步经历。请随时在Instagram上给我发私信 @That Psychology podcast。确保你在那边关注我们，这样你就可以对未来的剧集进行投票，了解即将推出什么内容，并且在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你现在正在收听的任何地方关注我们，给我们留下五星好评或订阅（如果你愿意的话），并确保
that you're taking care of yourself, be kind to yourself, be gentle to yourself. the fact that you have, you know, sought out this information is wonderful and I think kind of proves that you're on a great journey. So I'm super proud of you. And until next week, be kind, be gentle. And we will talk soon. On the Look Back at it podcast.
照顾好自己，善待自己，温柔对待自己。你寻求这些信息的行为是美妙的，我认为这证明了你正走在一段伟大的旅程上。所以我为你感到超级骄傲。直到下周，保持善良，保持温柔。我们很快就会交谈。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians,
1979年，对我来说那是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人，
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill, on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《从难处学起》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方说真的都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着西装，就像穿着盔甲一样？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《从难处学起》。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吧？我动过一次测试的手脚。这需要一支网络侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《被困的爱》（Love Trapped）。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
当同时也有自动扶梯可用时。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我剖析了心理坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的迹象。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。